Life feels complicated because we make
it complicated. What if the path to an
easier life isn't about doing more, but
about doing differently? The first
secret is effortless intentionality.
Ease comes not from avoiding effort, but
directing it toward what truly matters.
Most people have it backwards. The
second principle, micro simplicity. Our
brains freeze when faced with
overwhelming tasks. It's like trying to
eat an entire pizza in one bite. Break
everything down into tiny, manageable
steps. Third, practice decision energy
budgeting. We waste our best mental
energy on trivial choices. It's like
using a Ferrari to deliver newspapers.
Automate the unimportant to preserve
your mental firepower. Fourth, embrace
present tense living. We spend 90% of
our anxiety on problems that don't
actually exist. Solve only current
problems, not imaginary futures.
Finally, adopt
anti-perfectionism. Perfectionism is a
disease that masquerades as a virtue.
It's the equivalent of refusing to drive
your car until you can guarantee you'll
never hit a red light. These principles
compound together. The transformation
happens one decision at a time. The
journey to an easier life begins with a
single intentional step. Which principle
will you start with today? Let me know
in the comments.